[Musique]
c'est moins dur la deuxième fois je
trouve ouais le retour c'est plus facile
ça se passe un peu mieux et là je suis
plus en forme que la même étape je pense
à 4 thomas pesquet est encore revenue
sur terre après une deuxième mission de
six mois dans l'espace il doit avant
tout retrouver ses sens de terriens
parce que c'est les odeurs en fait les
gars qui viennent ou récupérés à toute
une équipe de fins de sauvetage secours
qui va nous récupérer moi je crois qu'il
sentait super bon la lessive et le
savons ce qui veut dire sans doute aussi
que nous on sentait pas forcément j'ai
envie d'une bonne douche je pense
premièrement et ça c'est une expérience
qui va être un peu spécial je pense
parce que dans la station évidemment dès
qu'on joue avec l'eau ça part un peu
dans tous les sens et là de voir toutes
les coûts de l'aide d'eau qui vont
tomber dans le même sens ça va être un
peu un peu comme un peu comme dans un
film de science fiction la pesanteur
c'est fini mais pour lui tout pèse
beaucoup plus lourd rien de soulever un
téléphone ça ça me paraissait absolument
on a l'impression qu'il ya vraiment un
élastique qui tire vers le bas parce que
c'est ça la gravité sans énormément on
énorme élastique qui tirent tout vers le
bas j'étais pas très stable je voyais
bien que je marchais pas très très droit
que quand je tourne quand je faisais le
virage un peu trop serré j'ai tendance à
partir un peu en dérapage mais
heureusement il ya des gens qui sont là
pour ça que ça se passe bien pour moi
thomas pesquet va maintenant enchaîner
les tests médicaux avec un programme de
remise en forme il a l'interdiction
formelle de conduite c'est d'une vraie
adaptation progressive parce que le
coeur doit reprendre sa forme syrienne
aux kurdes war grossir comme le sens
arrive rapidement au cerveau vu comment
la pesanteur et bien le quand même pas
besoin d'avoir cette forme aussi gros ce
qu'il a sur terre mais aussi redonner un
petit peu cette flexibilité et 7,7
aisance que nous avons sur terre de
lever les bras de lever les gens de
lever la tête chose qu'on a perdu quand
on est dans l'espace pendant sa mission
malgré deux heures de sport par jour
thomas pesquet a perdu à des muscles et
ses eaux sont beaucoup plus fragiles
c'est parti pour le foot y est
quotidien à bord de l iss
dans l'espace on flotte toute la journée
il ya beaucoup de muscles dont on se
sert pas les muscles du dos les effets
des crises en fait dans l'espace thomas
pesquet a pris un sacré coup de vieux on
dit qu'un astronaute à une algue esma
accélérée pendant son vol sur le plan
musculaire et sur le plan capacité à
l'effort je dirais qu'il faut mois de
récupération alors il ya quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus long c'est que ils
perdent
minéralisation osseuse et là il faut un
peu entre un an et deux ans d'un même
but des astronautes qui n'ont récupéré
qu'au bout de trois ans thomas pesquet
va maintenant enchaîner les expériences
scientifiques pendant plusieurs mois
pour comparer les données prises dans
l'espace est celle depuis son retour sur
terre et puis avant de rêver de lune ou
même de mars il a décidé de souffler un
peu ben ça je pense surtout à prendre un
peu de repos à prendre un peu de
vacances parce que la partie dans
l'espace évidemment à dure six mois elle
est très intense mais faut voir quelle
est toujours précédée par deux ans
d'entraînement qui sont moments aussi
intenses avaient suivi par six mois de
remise en forme de prélèvements
scientifiques participation à des
briefings et c'est donc en tout c'est
quand même à chaque fois trois quatre
ans de boulot donc là je vais enchaîner
quasiment deux fois de suite donc là il
va falloir que je prenne un peu un peu
de temps pour moi et pour mes proches et
puis ensuite on verra bien c'est vrai
qu'il faut se retrouver un challenge
mais je connais beaucoup d'astronomes
ont fait peut-être partie quand il peut
quand il part dans l'espace ils vont
cette fois sa dernière fois comme c'est
dur c'est quand même on souffre parce
quand même on est loin des siens donc
j'en connais beaucoup qui c'est la
dernière fois et puis après au bout de
six mois ils ont tous envie de repartir